EMILY FORTUNA: Here
are the top five things
people love about Flutter.
MARTIN AGUINIS: First
off, stateful hot reload.
This allows you to make
changes in your app
and see them appear in
action in less than a second.
Developers building
with Flutter complain
that they don't have time
to go get coffee or make tea
because their
builds are too fast.
In the unlikely event that
hot reload is insufficient,
a hot restart of your app
also only takes a few seconds
and you're back in action.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Writing a separate iOS
and Android app
has the potential
to introduce twice as many
bugs and results in twice as
much code that you need
to test and maintain.
It can be hard to also
ensure that each app has
feature parity as it grows.
With Flutter, all your
code for iOS and Android
are in a single codebase,
speeding up development
and making test coverage easier.
MARTIN AGUINIS:
Flutter aims to provide
60 frames per second
app performance
with smooth
jank-free animations.
Your code is compiled
ahead of time
so there's no
interpretation happening,
meaning that the Flutter
engine is executing
machine instructions
for lightning
fast native performance.
EMILY FORTUNA: An app
written with Flutter
has a great collection
of built-in components
that are appropriate for the
platform you're developing on,
so there's no need to learn
two completely different
development systems to make your
app feel natural to your users.
MARTIN AGUINIS: If it
looks good on this device,
will it look good
on this other phone?
If it's written using
Flutter, the answer is yes.
Flutter uses its
own rendering engine
to draw the entire UI to screen.
This allows all components
of your app to be performant
and provides consistency
from device to device.
EMILY FORTUNA: Let us know
what your favorite feature is.
[MUSIC PLAYING]